bénis-moi Père car j'ai péché
combien de temps depuis ta dernière confession mon
fils 27 heures c'est vraiment trop souvent
tu n'es pas si mal d'entendre des
images capitales comme tu le sais des millions de personnes se
tournent vers nous pour des informations et de l'élévation
et oui du divertissement et nous sommes  va le
donner à une action temporelle
une armée de techniciens et d'acteurs et d'
artistes de premier ordre travaillant dur
pour porter à l'écran notre plus grande
sortie de l'année Hail Caesar est une
image de prestige avec l'une des plus grandes
stars du monde Baird Whitlock un
vérité, nous pourrions voir si nous avions mais si nous
ha hé hé hé ah mr.  Mannix quoi de neuf
interacteur ne peut pas trouver Baird Whitlock
quelqu'un l'a glissé sous ma porte nous
avons votre star de cinéma recueillir 100 000 $ dans
les instructions d'attente qui sommes-nous le
futur
bonjour Bert m.  Mannix Lawrence Obie
merci à tous d'être venus
le studio a besoin de votre aide mauvais Whitlock
a été kidnappé c'est fou fou pour le
chef star de cinéma passons 24 heures mais
nous le cherchons nous ne le voulons pas
dans les colonnes de potins ça va  coûter
beaucoup d'argent au studio c'est là que
vous entrez j'ai besoin d'argent nous devons
avoir des avant-bras très forts
est-ce difficile de le serrer comme ça ça fait
partie du travail mademoiselle j'aimerais savoir
ce qui se passe ici 20
millions  les lecteurs veulent la vérité Eddie
vérité
oui c'est un drame mec c'est un vrai drame
m.  Mannix, je sais que ça a l'air tordu mais
quelqu'un appelle du futur bon
seigneur pour
se demander ce qui se passe